[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland eurem
täglichen True Crime Podcast wir sind
Mirko Kasimir und Natalie Strauß und die
heutige Folge ist ein bisschen anders
als sonst also nicht dass wir hier sonst
immer dasselbe erzählen oder so aber
normalerweise dreht es sich bei uns und
eigentlich auch in allen anderen
Podcasts um die Tat und um die Täter die
Opfer die Ermittlung und um den Prozess
das haben wir heute auch alles drin aber
im Mittelpunkt stehen die Zeugen es geht
um den Mord an der 28-Jährigen Kitty
genovies im Jahr 1964 in Queens New York
und Mirko am besten ist es vielleicht
wenn du uns mal aus dem Artikel der New
York Times vorliest der ungefähr zwei
Wochen nach diesem Mord erschienen ist
mit lautet 37 die einen Mord sein riefen
nicht die Polizei
mehr als eine halbe Stunde lang
beobachten 38 ehrbare gesetzestreue
Bürger in Queens wie ein Mörder eine
Frau und drei verschiedenen Angriffen
verfolgte und erstach zwei Mal wurde er
durch den Klang der Stimmen der Anwohner
und das plötzliche aufleuchten ihrer
schlafzimmerbeleuchtungen unterbrochen
und verscheucht jedes Mal kehrte er
zurück suchte die Frau auf und stach
erneut auf sie ein während des Angriffs
rief niemand die Polizei ein einziger
Zoll gemeldete sich nachdem die Frau tot
war das war auf den Tag genau vor zwei
Wochen aber der stellvertretende chefins
backter Frederick im Larson ist immer
noch schockiert nicht weil es sich um
einen Mord handelt sondern weil die
guten Leute es versäumt haben die
Polizei zu rufen
Wahnsinn oder da wird mir echt eiskalt
als die Polizei dann endlich gerufen
wird ist es für die junge Frau Kitty
genovies zu spät die Polizei befragt
Zeugen warum sie die Polizei nicht eher
gerufen haben und Mirko lies mal bitte
vor was einer erzeugen darauf
geantwortet hat der Mann erklärte er
habe nach langem Zögern die Polizei
gerufen er habe einen Freund in Nassau
County um Rat gefragt und sei dann über
das Dach des Gebäudes in die Wohnung
einer älteren Frau gegangen um sie zum
Anrufen zu bewegen
ich wollte mich nicht einmischen
erklärte er der Polizei verlegen
entschuldigung ich wollte mich nicht
einmischen
dieser Satz schockiert die New Yorker
und schließlich die ganze Welt als immer
mehr amerikanische und auch
internationale Medien die Geschichte
aufgreifen der Satz wird zum Synonym für
Entfremdung und Anonymität in den
Großstädten und für urbane Apathie der
Mord löst psychologische Untersuchungen
aus die schließlich zur Postulierung des
zuschauereffekts auch genovies-syndrom
genannt führen und er befeuert die White
flight die Flucht der weißen
Mittelschicht aus den Innenstädten in
die Vorstädte die ganze Sache schlägt
wirklich riesen Wellen und ist bis heute
ins kollektive Gedächtnis der USA
eingebrannt es sind Massen von Artikeln
und Büchern dazu erschienen mit Titeln
wie der Mord der Amerika veränderte es
gibt Songs und Theaterstücke in Serien
von law and order bis Seinfeld wird
darauf Bezug genommen die Story
inspiriert die Figur des Rorschach aus
der super selten Serie Watchmen immer
wieder macht man das Fernsehen die
Anonymität der Großstadt die Abkehr vom
Glauben oder die kapitalistische
raubtiermoral verantwortlich echt das
ist aber auch so eine Geschichte die
einen wirklich an der Menschheit
zweifeln lässt wie kann man nur so
abstumpfen dass man eine Mord zu sieht
ohne die Polizei zu rufen das geht nicht
hier mein Kopf allein dieser Satz aus
dem Artikel mehr als eine halbe Stunde
lang beobachten 38 ehrbare Gesetz des
Treue Bürger in Queens wie ein Mörder
eine Frau in drei verschiedenen
Angriffen verfolgte und erstarrt das ist
unfassbar und einfach nur zum Kotzen das
macht mich richtig wütend und macht mir
auch gleichzeitig Angst weil ich meine
was ist wenn ich selber mal in eine
Notlage komme sondern auch alle weg oder
wie läuft das dann oder wenn sie nur
Schweigen drum stehen und dann im
Nachhinein erklären ich wollte da nicht
reingezogen werden
es gibt eigentlich nur einen einzigen
Lichtblick
denn die Geschichte stimmt so nicht
Dankeschön ein Plot Twist und ich muss
sagen einer für den ich extrem dankbar
bin obwohl der traurigste Punkt der ist
leider wahr denn kritische novies wurde
ermordet aber bevor wir uns diesen Mord
und die Geschichte der 38 schweigenden
zeugen noch mal genauer anschauen
erzählen wir von Kitty also es ist
Katherine Susan genovies genannt Kitty
wird am 7 juli 1935 im Brooklyn New York
geboren sie ist das älteste von fünf
Kindern ihrer italienisch-amerikanischen
Eltern in ihrer Schulzeit ist sie
richtig beliebt sind viele Freunde ist
lustig hat offenbar so ein ganz
besonderes Talent dafür die Lehrer
nachzuahmen bekannte beschreiben sie als
Selbstbewusstsein Alter mit so einem
richtig tollen sonnigen Gemüt nach der
Schule und nachdem sie bei ihren Eltern
ausgezogen ist arbeitet sie eine Weile
im Büro Jobs
aber die sind ihr zu langweilig und zu
beginnt sie in den späten 50er Jahren
als Barkeeperin zu arbeiten
1961 wird sie kurzzeitig verhaftet weil
sie verbotener Weise von Gästen der Bar
Wetten auf Pferderennen angenommen hat
und dabei an einen Lockvogel der Polizei
geraten ist es gibt nicht viele Fotos
von ihr im Netz aber eins das relativ
häufig geteilt wurde bzw häufig gefunden
wurde das ist dieser maxshot das Foto
dass die Polizei von ihr nach der
Verhaftung gemacht hat das ist jetzt
natürlich nicht unbedingt so super
optimales Bild und von ihrem sonnigen
Gemüt ist selbstverständlicherweise auch
nicht so viel zu sehen aber man bekommt
dennoch eine sehr guten Eindruck und
zwar von seiner frechen selbstbewussten
jungen Frau sieht kurze Haare so ein
bisschen strubbelig sie trägt darauf
eine karierte Bluse ist könnte fast ein
Holzfällerhemd sein und sie wird
Bushidos und ihr Blick ist nicht Schuld
bewusst sondern ihr herausfordern und so
ein bisschen frech ich mag das Bild
ehrlich gesagt und ich kann mir
vorstellen ich würde sie mögen
aus 50 Dollar Strafe zahlen sie wird
entlassen und sucht sich einen Job in
einer anderen Bar der FS eleven auerbar
in Queens die Sie bald im Auftrag des
Besitzers leitet sie macht häufig
Doppelschichten um Geld zu sparen denn
eines Tages möchte sie ihr eigenes
italienisches Restaurant öffnen in
dieser Zeit wohnt sie in einer Wohnung
in der OST in street die sie sich mit
einer Frauen namens Mary and silenco
teilt Mary Ann ist nicht nur eine
Mitbewohnerin die beiden sind ein paar
Kittys lesbisch das sollte für unsere
Geschichte eigentlich keine Rolle
spielen tut es aber den homosexualität
ist in den frühen 60er Jahren verboten
es gibt viel Gewalt gegen Schwule und
Lesben die Szene trifft sich deshalb in
illegalen Clubs die immer wieder von der
Polizei gestürmt werden ja dann kann man
wohl davon ausgehen dass viele Leute aus
dieser Szene in der Polizei nicht
unbedingt den besten Freund und Helfer
gesehen haben ja ganz sicher nicht am 13
märz 1964 verlässt Kitty gegen 2
und macht sich in ihrem roten Fiat auf
den Heimweg gegen 3:15 Uhr parkt sie in
der Nähe ihrer Wohnung ungefähr 30 Meter
von der Haustür entfernt Entschuldigung
warte mal 3:15 Uhr also mitten in der
Nacht sollen 38 Leute eine halbe Stunde
lang im Mord zugeschaut haben also das
schon ein bisschen komisch ja auf jeden
Fall deswegen kommen wir jetzt an den
Punkt wo wir die Geschichte so erzählen
wie sie sich wohl wirklich zugetragen
hat und nicht wie sie in dem Artikel
erzählt wird
vielleicht reden wir gleich mal über
diese Zahl 38 38 Leute die eine halbe
Stunde lang im Mord zu sehen wie sie
später herausstellt ist 38 nicht die
Anzahl der Zeugen sondern die Anzahl von
Nachbarn die im folgenden Tag von der
Polizei befragt werden und von den viele
absoluten Nichts zu den Ermittlungen
beitragen können ganz einfach weil sie
nämlich geschlafen haben
aber weiter im Text als ich Kitty auf
den Weg zu ihrer Wohnung in einem
zweistöckigen Apartmentgebäude macht
bemerkt sie dass sie verfolgt wird und
dass ihr Verfolger ein Messer hat Kitty
beginnt zu rennen ihr erstes Ziel ist
eine Bar in der Straße die oft um diese
Uhrzeit noch geöffnet ist wahrscheinlich
um Schutz zu suchen doch die erreicht
sie gar nicht erst ihr Verfolger holt
sie ein und sticht ihr von hinten
zweimal in den Rücken die Klinge
verletzt ihren Lunge aber trotzdem
gelingt es ihr zu schreien irgendwo
öffnet sich ein Fenster jemand schreit
heraus lief that girl alone dass das
Mädchen in Ruhe und tatsächlich der
Angreifer macht sich aus dem Staub für
den Zeugen am Fenster scheint die Sache
damit erledigt ähm moment mal der wird
zweimal auf eine Frau eingestochen und
der Typ aus seinem Fenster bzw aus
seiner sicheren Wohnung ruft hau ab und
das war's ja das ist zwar nicht
unbedingt was ich als eine halbe Stunde
eine Mord zu schauen ohne was zu
unternehmen bezeichnen würde aber er
krass ist es auf jeden Fall aber
irgendwie auch zu verstehen nicht zu
entschuldigen aber zu verstehen ich
meine es gibt dort diese Bar und es ist
nichts Besonderes dass sich Leute dafür
prügeln oder dass ein betrunkener Mann
seine Frau schlägt es ist krass zu sagen
ein gewalttätiger Ehemann ist eine
Familienangelegenheit und nur sehr sehr
wenige Menschen mischen sich und sowas
ein mehrere Zeugen sagen hinterher dass
sie von einem gewalttätigen Ehemann
ausgegangen sind und sich darum nicht
einmischen wollten man muss auch wissen
dass diese Straße dunkel ist es gibt
zwar Lampen aber das sind ja mehr oder
weniger nur billige Funzeln wer zu
diesem Zeitpunkt herausschaut sieht also
wahrscheinlich nur eine Frau die
vielleicht schwanken herumläuft was man
sich dann Betrunkenheit erklären kann
und einen Mann der das Weite sucht
interessant ist auch noch folgendes zwei
Leute sagen später sie hätten schon zu
Beginn des Angriffs die Polizei gerufen
eine Nachbarin die nur gebrochene
Englisch spricht behauptet der
Polizistin Telefon sei wegen ihres
schlechten Englisch aggressiv geworden
so dass sie dann irgendwann verängstlich
aufgelegt hat ob das stimmt lässt sich
heute nicht mehr beweisen oder
widerlegen denn Notrufe werden damals
nicht aufgezeichnet es gibt ja noch
nicht mal einen Notruf wie wir ihn heute
kennen die Leute müssen in der
zuständigen Polizeiwache oder bei der
Auskunft anrufen und das noch ein sehr
interessantes Detail denn der berühmte
Notruf 91 der wurde erst als Reaktion
auf genau diesem Mord eingeführt okay
Mirko Kitty ist schwer verletzt aber am
Leben und der Täter ist geflohen ja aber
er kommt zurück dieser Typ haut ab
nachdem jemand aus dem Fenster gebrüllt
hat geht zu seinem Auto fährt weg kommt
zurück und packt an einer anderen Stelle
wie er packt um das ist echt so krank er
parkt um und wechselt den Hut damit die
niemand wiedererkennt und macht sich
wieder auf die Suche nach Kitty er
findet sie schließlich in einem Flur an
der Rückseite des apartmentkomplexes
übrigens ist sie dort außerhalb der
Sichtweite aller Nachbarn ja von wegen
die haben eine halbe Stunde lang gekotzt
selbst wenn sie gewollt hätten dass der
gar nicht gegangen ist unmöglich gewesen
in der Situation Kitty ist nur halb bei
Bewusstsein aber Messer wohnten an ihren
Händen beweisen dass sie sich gewehrt
haben muss aber sie hat keine Chance der
Täter sticht zwölf Mal auf sie ein dann
versucht er sie zu vergewaltigen steht
ihr 49 $ und rennt weg
[Musik]
Kitty stirbt in diesem Flur aber nicht
wieder Artikel suggeriert allein während
die braven Bürger wieder schlafen gehen
wir müssen an der Stelle auf den man
zurückkommen der diesen Satz sagte ich
wollte nicht hineingezogen werden Karl
Ross was diesen Satz von ihm noch
schlimmer macht er ist eigentlich ein
Freund von Kitty eröffnet seine Tür und
sieht den zweiten Angriff und macht die
Tür wieder zu okay da kann man jetzt
sagen er hat Angst vor dem Mörder wir
sind weiß Gott nicht alle Helden die
sich einem Mann mit einem Messer in den
Weg stellen aber warum zum Teufel ruft
er nicht die Polizei tja Karl Ross ist
schwul und hat vor der Polizei fast
genauso viel Angst wie vor dem Täter und
das steckt hinter der Aussage ich wollte
nicht hineingezogen werden nicht das hat
mich nicht interessiert sondern ich
hatte Angst ja okay aber das ist doch
keine Entschuldigung dafür die eigene
Freundin so dermaßen im Stich lassen auf
gar keinen Fall und Carl Ross verhält
sich hier falsch Grund falsch da gibt es
für mich gar keinen Zweifel er greift
nicht ein er ruft nicht die Polizei aber
er tut etwas anderes etwas das aus
heutiger Sicht sehr unüberlegter scheint
vielleicht sollte man auch noch erwähnen
dass er zu diesem Zeitpunkt sehr
betrunken war er ruft eine Freundin an
fragt sie was er tun soll und die sagt
ihm aus der Ferne wahrscheinlich aus
Angst um ihn zu schützen dass er sich da
bloß nicht einmischen soll statt also
direkt einzugreifen oder die Polizei zu
rufen klettert Karl Ross betrunken wie
er war aus seinem Fenster aufs Dach des
Hauses und von dort in einen anderen
Aufgang klopft eine Nachbarin aus dem
Schlaf und sagt ihr sie solle die
Polizei alarmieren ja Überraschung das
dauert natürlich alles viel zu lange der
Anruf bei der Freundin dann der
kletterparkour dann muss erst doch die
andere Freundin geweckt und überzeugt
werden und das alles während der Mörder
auf Kitty einsticht und sie
vergewaltigen will während also jede
Sekunde zählt na wie gesagt es ist ein
schrecklicher Fehler den Carl rosster
begangen hat ja aber naja ich sag mal so
aus dem Fenster zu steigen und übers
Dach zu klettern für mich klingt das
jetzt auch nicht nach einem total
teilnahmslosen Menschen für mich klingt
das eher nach jemandem der in einer
Notsituation in Panik und betrunken
völlig planlos irrational und falsch
handelt aber immerhin versucht das
Richtige zu tun ja ich weiß nicht ob man
sein Verhalten entschuldigen kann aber
man kann es vielleicht ein bisschen
verstehen die Nachbarin die die Polizei
alarmiert weckt außerdem noch eine
andere Nachbarin so viel Fahrer eine
gute Freundin von Kitty und die zögert
keinen Augenblick und stürmt aus ihrer
Wohnung ihr Mann versucht sie noch
zurückzuhalten aus Angst denn niemand
weiß ob der Mörder noch bei Kitty ist
aber Sophie achtet nicht auf ihn als
ihre Freundin erreicht ist der Täter
verschwunden Kitty stirbt egal wie
schwach der Trost auch ist sie stirbt in
den Armen ihrer Freundin die ohne
Rücksicht auf die Gefahr ganz eigenen
Lebens zu ihr geeilt ist auch das ist
ein Teil der Geschichte über die
angebliche Kälte der Großstadt ja wir
müssen noch mal ganz kurz über Mary ein
zielonko sprechen ihre Freundin und
Partnerin die verschläft den Mord und
wird am nächsten Tag von der Polizei
vernommen und sie wird für ein paar Tage
die Hauptverdächtige ja eigentlich schon
Wahnsinn oder ich meine es gibt doch die
Zeugenaussagen dass sie von einem Mann
attackiert wurde aber offensichtlich hat
sich da jemand bei der Polizei gesagt
die meisten Morde sind Beziehungstaten
meistens geht es um Eifersucht und naja
diese Frau ist homosexuell also schon
per se schuldig boah na klar
Homosexualität war ja eh schon illegal
und da war es ja bis zu einem Mord auch
nur noch so ein ganz kleiner Schritt
also wirklich Mary Ann erzählt später
dass es in der Befragung immer wieder um
ihr Sexleben ging welche Stellung Kitty
und sie bevorzugt und euch komisches
Zeugs und ehrlich von meinem Auge sehe
ich da ein paar richtig widerliche
sabbernde Detectives mit so speckigen
Trenchcoats Zigarette im Mund die gar
nicht genug von solchen Geschichten
kriegen können so ekelhaft aber okay da
hast du jetzt gerade meine Fantasie mit
mir durchgegangen aber zum Glück wird
bald der wahre Täter geschnappt ja aber
warte mal kurz das sehen wir uns noch
einen Moment auf wir müssen noch über
einen zweiten Zeug reden du meinst
Joseph Fink ganz genau Joseph Fink er
stellvertretende Hausmeister das
Apartmenthauses gegenüber und er sieht
den Angriff ganz genau er kann sogar das
Messer erkennen und entscheidet sich
nichts zu unternehmen
spricht genau dem Bild dass der New York
Times Artikel von allen Nachbarn
zeichnen will er sagt tatsächlich dass
er daran dachte seinen Baseballschläger
zu holen aber dann hat er doch lieber
ein Nickerchen gemacht
es gibt wirklich solche Leute ist
unfassbar und es gibt solche Leute ohne
Herz und noch mehr Leute die unsicher
sind und aus Angst nichts oder das
falsche Unternehmen wie bereits gesagt
wir sind weiß Gott nicht alle Helden
aber zum Glück sind nur sehr wenige von
uns so kaltherzig und apathisch wie
Joseph Fink es gibt zum Beispiel eine
Studie für die mehr als 1.000 Videos von
Prügeleien Vergewaltigungen und
Mordversuchen ausgewertet wurden die
Überwachungskameras in Kopenhagen
Kapstadt Amsterdam und London
aufgezeichnet hatten wenn es Zeugen gab
kamen sie den Opfern in 90% der Fälle zu
Hilfe also was ich oft lese ist wenn
insbesondere in solchen Situationen wie
bei Kitty ähm diese Männer oder diese
Menschen die andere attackieren die
lassen oft ab wenn man sich ah Wert und
wenn man richtig stumm macht wenn man
rumschreibt aber am Ende des Tages
wissen wir alle nicht wie werden solche
Situation reagieren würden das kann sein
dass die lauteste Person ganz leise wird
oder oder aber wichtig ist Hilfe holen
auf jeden Fall Hilfe holen auf jeden
Fall das ist glaube ich das sehr
wichtigste Punkt okay aber kommen wir
jetzt noch mal zu Kitty zurück und dazu
wieder Mord an ihr aufgeklärt wurde denn
fünf Tage nach dem Mord beobachtet oder
in einer anderen Gegend von Queens wie
ein Mann einen Fernseher aus dem Haus
eines Nachbarn trägt Raul spricht ihn an
und der Fremde behauptet er würde bei
einem Umzug helfen raul ist misstrauisch
er weiß von keinem Umzug und ruft einen
weiteren Nachbarn Jack Brown den fragte
ob die bennesters umziehen Jack ist sich
sicher dass sie das nicht tun die beiden
zögern nicht Raul ruft die Polizei Jack
rennt auf die Straße und macht das Auto
des Mannes fahr und tauglich die Polizei
kann den Einbrecher kurz darauf am
Tatort schnappen es ist der 29-Jährige
Winston Mosley der Polizei fällt auf
dass sein Auto der Beschreibung eines
Wagens entspricht den Zeugen während des
Mordes an Kitty genovies gesehen haben
wollen Mosley gesteht in Mord ohne
irgendwelche Umschweife und einen
weiteren Mord an einer jungen Frau der
bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt ungelöst war ist
das nicht unglaublich dieser Mord bei
dem angeblich 38 Leute zugeschaut und
sich nicht dafür interessiert haben wird
letztendlich dadurch aufgelöst dass zwei
Männer darauf achten was in ihrer
Nachbarschaft vor sich geht und beherzt
genau das Richtige tun ja das ist für
mich auch irgendwie die größte Ironie an
der ganzen Geschichte aber all das
erfährt damals niemand erst seit Anfang
der 2000er wird manchmal die wahre
Geschichte des Mordes seinen Kitty
genovies erzählt naja ich schätze mal
dieses Story mit dem apathischen
Nachbarn war einfach besser oder
zumindest sensationeller und jeder
konnte sie her nehmen um seine Meinung
zu untermauern vom erzkonservativen
Priester der sich über den moralischen
Verfall wegen der Abkehr von Gott
ereiferte bis zur sowjetischen Presse
die sagen konnte guck mal was der böse
Kapitalismus aus den Herzen der Menschen
macht es gab da einen Journalisten
namens Danny Minen der die ganze
Geschichte von Anfang an anzweifelte er
hatte herausgefunden dass die meisten
echten Augenzeugen nur die verletzte
Kitty gesehen hatten und sie für eine
torkelnde betrunkene hielten Minen
fragte den Autor des New York Times
Artikels warum davon in seiner
Geschichte kein Wort zu lesen war die
Antwort war deutlich weil das die Story
verdorben hätte
ich bin sehr froh dass wir hier diese
Story gründlich verdorben haben mir
gefällt die wahre Geschichte besser wenn
man das in diesem Zusammenhang überhaupt
zu sagen kann ja man geht auch ein
bisschen ruhiger durchs Leben wenn man
weiß dass man nicht ausschließlich von
herzlosen Zombies umgeben ist
für die Story von Kitty und den 38
Zeugen haben wir eine ganze Reihe von
Quellen verwendet zum selber nachlesen
oder hören können wir besonders die
Episode Kitty genovace er beißt denn der
Appetit des Podcast your wron About und
das Buch von Rudger Brechmann im Grunde
gut empfehlen vielen Dank dass ihr dabei
wart und natürlich bis zur nächsten
Ausgabe Tatort Deutschlands eure Natalie
und euer Merkur